die tat sei
dass der raum voll ist dieser herr nolle
angesprochen hat die ist ganz leicht zu
erklären denn ich habe den eindruck dass
wir wirklich ein ganz tolles programm
haben und dieses programm wird der grund
dafür sein dass so viele interessenten
hierhergekommen sind also ich möchte
mich auch ganz herzlich bei allen
vortragenden gedanken dass sie gekommen
sind und ich freue mich also schon sehr
auf diese veranstaltung so jetzt fange
ich mit meinem vortrag an und dieser
vortrag sollen über voraussetzungen
gehen oder über die reflexion auf
voraussetzungen und zwar erste
voraussetzungen voraussetzungen die soba
saal sind die so grundlegend sind dass
wir sie unter umständen gar nicht
bemerken weil sie hinter unserem rücken
sind und bei allem was wir sagen schon
irgendwo akzeptiert sind
das wird dann zwar von anderen manchmal
erkannt aber von uns selber unter
umständen gar nicht oder erst im letzten
augenblick einer der anlässe für diese
tagung war für mich die erfahrung die
ich immer wieder während der
lehrtätigkeit in bonn machen musste dass
nämlich viele begriffe in der
philosophie in sehr diversen kontexten
auftreten und es nur zu oft nicht klar
ist welches zugrundeliegende
philosophische paradigma die
inanspruchnahme dieser begriffe leitete
im fall des geist begriffs erinnere ich
an die verwirrende situation die sich
daraus ergeben hat dass die deutschen
übersetzer englischsprachige texte zur
sprach analytischen philosophie den
begriff einer philosophie auf meint
umstandslos mit philosophie des geistes
übersetzen was uns die wir in der
sprache tradition des deutschen
idealismus aufgewachsen sind in große
verwirrung gestoßen hat zumal die
erfahrung zeigt dass die verschiedenen
philosophischen
rath paradigmen mit einem wort von
anthony kennedy gesprochen bis heute
convenience die warter kalt sind also
derartig gegeneinander abgeschottet das
eigentlich keine wirkliche verständigung
auch nur versucht wird der grund für
dieses gegenseitige unverständnis dass
wir ja auch hierzulande kennen wo sich
die unterschiedlichen philosophischen
positionen ja auch meisten zeit nicht
viel zu sagen haben liegt meiner
einschätzung nach an den jeweils
zugrundeliegenden und verschwiegenen
voraussetzungen voraus schon die
methodische intention folgt die mich zur
planung dieses symposiums veranlasst hat
mir erscheint es sinnvoll den geist
begriff unter einem solchen viele unter
einem solchen philosophischen paradigma
zu diskutieren in welchem es möglich ist
die geltung ebensolche verschwiegener
voraussetzungen zu reflektieren die
absicht dabei wäre es als
philosophischen primär begriff oder
prinzipien begriff zu begründen oder zu
erläutern
mir ist bewusst dass ich mich mit dieser
anfangs bedingung selbst bereits auf
eine idealistische position festlegen
aber das ist unumgänglich bekanntermaßen
unterscheidet sich die philosophie von
den wissenschaften ja unter anderem
dadurch dass wir uns etwa in methoden
fragen nicht auf eine meta-ebene
zurückziehen können sondern immer von
einer bestimmten perspektive aus
die anderen positionen betrachten
deshalb gehe ich in meiner naivität auf
eine grundforderung zurück die freilich
insofern einseitig ist als sie auch
wieder nur sagen wir mal den
platonischen mainstream der
traditionalismus abbildet die forderung
nach letzte
begründung dazu möchte ich den
kämpferischen transzendentale
philosophen hans wagener zitieren
der schreibt solange die philosophen
noch schreiben und reden und so lange
sie mit dem geschriebenen und geredeten
noch etwas meinen und solange sie mit
die für diese ihre meinung nach wahrheit
noch wahrheitsanspruch erheben so lange
ist das thema der letzt und selbst
begründung dass schlechterdings
unerlässliche thema der philosophie denn
einen wahrheitsanspruch für etwas
erheben
dies ist gleichbedeutend mit dem
behauptung des begründbar und begründet
sein begründbar bzw begründet ist etwas
nur dank etwas anderes nämlich den grund
dass also ein grund sein soll wahrheit
verweist immer auf einen begründung
zusammenzustellen uhr erwiesen werden
muss und ist letztlich nichts anderes
als eben diese begründung zusammenhang
dieser zusammenhang ist also logisch
gegliedert in grund und folge das heißt
er besteht aus einem abhängigen oder
bedingten und auf der anderen seite den
logischen bedingungen andererseits her
diese bedingungen sind als logische
bedingungen notwendig aber nicht
hinreichen sie sind nicht bedingungen
der wirklichkeit von etwas sondern der
möglichkeit von begriffen nicht von
erscheinungen
ich gehe allerdings davon aus dass unter
den hier behandelten autoren eine ganze
reihe von philosophen sind die diesen
idealismus aus den verschiedensten
gründen ablehnen oder zurückweisen
werden
also das bezieht sich in erster linie
auf den morgigen tag und die rede von
den von der krise des geistes ich denke
da an lebensphilosophie single oder
miete
ich bin gespannt darauf was dazu hier zu
sagen sein wird ich komme jetzt auf kant
zu sprechen kann ist nach meiner
überzeugung dass große verdient
zuzusprechen durch seine kritische um
wendung der dinge eine reihe sehr starke
argumente vorgetragen zu haben die im
grunde einen konsistenten verzicht auf
letzte begründung unmöglich machen und
recht besehen einen solchen verzicht
seien und es touristisch oder
rassistisch motiviert nur um den preis
einer wenn das mal mit einem begriff von
louis weit weg in dem kleid einer welt
die defizite der philosophie zuzulassen
zu lassen
punk ist für mich also zugleich der
lieferant des paradigmas unter dem ich
diese ganze philosophische diskussion
betrachtet weil sein denken sozusagen
nach programms rasiermesser die
geringste zahl meter führenden
metaphysische oder irrationaler
vorannahmen verlangt so also jetzt
zukommt wie gesagt ich gehe von seiner
unterscheidung in schul begriff und welt
begriff der philosophie aus kann für
damit deutlich machen dass es unter
voraussetzungen einer kritischen
untersuchung eigentlich nur einen
einzigen begriff von der philosophie
geben kann
die nach dem welt begriff nimmt wobei
hier begriff natürlichen nicht in einem
aristotelischen sinne einer art begriff
verstanden wird sondern als idee prinzip
oder grund
als solcher hat er kein referenzobjekt
sondern lediglich eine logische oder
continental logische funktion zur
rechtfertigung eines wahrheitsanspruch
kann spricht hier auch von einem urbild
der philosophie also als philosophie
nach ihrem welt begriff betrachtet
bezeichnet kann die wissenschaft von der
beziehung aller erkenntnis auf die
wesentlichen zwecke der menschlichen
vernunft ideologie ration ist humane
womit deutlich gemacht wird dass das
dialektische aufsuchen der gründe und
prinzipien ein normatives geschäft ist
die philosophie intendiert also
notwendig die systematische einheit
aller vernunft erkenntnisse in dem sie
auf diese weise die letzten bedingungen
des wissens im wissen aufsucht betrifft
diese art der philosophie dasjenige was
jedermann notwendig interessierten
anmerkung kampf zu den wesentlichen
zwecken sagt kann die tiere ihn an
dieser programmatischen stelle
wesentliche zwecke sind darum noch nicht
zu
dennoch nicht die höchsten deren nur ein
einziger sein kann daher etwas weiter
daher sind sie entweder der endzweck
oder subalterne zwecke die zu jedem zu
jenem als mittel notwendig gehören diese
entwächst kann ist kein anderer art die
ganze bestimmung des menschen und die
philosophie über dieselbe heiß moral
die philosophie nachdem welt begriff ist
mithin eine kritische geltung reflexion
dabei werden die inhalte und ereignisse
der denkt tätigkeit des vernunft lesen
gedanken begriffe urteile schlüssel
theorien sozusagen intention als ob
league war also reflexiv vor dieses
denken der bewusstsein gebracht um sie
auf ihre geltung und wahrheit zu prüfen
begriff der prüfung es auch wichtig sie
eruiert also diese reflexion hier die
bedingungen und prinzipien möglicher
geltung und wahrheit und wären im
begriff und mit das ist ein wort von
handwagen sie misst an diesem an diesem
begriff die zu prüfenden nur diese
geltung theoretische reflexion ist
logisch oder genauer dann für ein tal
logische reflexion die das gesamt der
erkenntnis und wahrheit' bedingungen
formuliert diese erkenntnis bedingungen
stammen und daher nicht aus der
erfahrung sondern sind die genuine
leistung des subjektiven bewusstseins
wenn wir jetzt unter diesen
voraussetzungen einer kantischen
frankenthal philosophie nach dem geist
fragen so bleibt uns gar keine andere
wahl als den geist begriff als mögliches
strukturprinzip des kosmos neue fassade
des denkens zu grunde zu legen alles
andere in bezug auf die in der literatur
oft als chamäleon hafte
bedeutungsvielfalt angesprochene
unsicherheit fällt aus da die einzigen
möglichen merkmale des begriffs
lediglich die zuordnung zum realen oder
idealen sein können
hartmut buchner fasst diese notwendige
grundannahme in seinem geist artikel im
handbuch philosophische grundbegriffe in
dem alten handbuch von 19
daher sind sich in die einfache formel 1
ist die realität des denkens
nun hat kannte natürlich muss
nun hat kant nicht wie etwa die
philosophen des deutschen idealismus
oder auch lebens philosophen wie himmel
und nietzsche einen gleichsam
definierten geist begriff allerdings für
befasst er sich mit dem begriff des
geistes zum beispiel in der
vorchristlichen schrift träume eines
geisterseher wo es allerdings nicht um
den geist sondern um die geister im
plural geht geister im sinne von
gespenstern auch in der kritik der
urteilskraft gibt es eine stelle wo er
den geist als belebendes prinzip in
gemüte bezeichnet was allerdings weil es
sich mit der begründung oder der
erläuterung des fini begriff beschäftigt
hier weniger in betracht kommt der tag
gehe ich davon aus dass wie gesagt kann
sich erstmal nicht mit dem begriff des
geistes als einer festen größe
beschäftigt hat versuche daher jetzt zu
den begrifflichen voraussetzungen
wiederum zurückzugehen die bei kann so
etwas wie das verständnis des geistes
grund legen können diesem grund sehe ich
im vernunft begriff muss mich ein
bisschen verständnis bitten
ich habe große rückenprobleme deswegen
fliege ich nicht jetzt hier so auf dich
mischpult tut mir leid weg zu rollen
gut also der vernunft begriff meine
damen und herren markiert bekannt die
oberste beziehungsweise letzte den
wissen erreichbare formale voraussetzung
er bezeichnet so die denkt notwendige
voraussetzung sinnvollen fragens
überhaupt und zwar egal ob es sich um
wissen bzw erkenntnis in einem
wissenschaftlichen oder auch schon im
vorwissenschaftlichen lebensweltlichen
oder alltags bereich handelt
nun besteht das wesentliche unseres
wissens darin dass es sich nicht
gleichsam im einzelnen verliert oder
dieses einzelne bloß abbildet sondern
dass es dieses einzelne im allgemeinen
also durch begriffe vorstellt dafür aber
ist wie schon angedeutet ein moment von
vernünftigkeit beansprucht dass sich
nicht aus der erfahrung selbst hier
leitet sondern umgekehrt seinerseits die
einheit der erfahrung erst verbürgt
daher bedeutet für kant die vernunft im
weitesten sinn oder vermögen ab rio
rische erkenntnis über überhaupt wenn
aperiodische erkenntnis per definitionem
nicht sinnliche sondern begriffliche
erkenntnis ist vernunft erkenntnis aus
begriffen aber genau das ist was eben
als philosophische erkenntnis
angesprochen wird oder wurde dann ist im
sinne kampf philosophie in das system
der vernunft erkenntnisse durch begriffe
wenn außerdem das wirken seines seine
seine wiesen nach
wenn außerdem das wissen seinem wesen
nach ein ganzes ausmachen soll
das eben war ja die voraussetzung der
begründbar kite wenn also erkenntnis
systematisch sein soll dann so kann's
ausgangsthese stellt die idee der
vernunft ein prinzip bereits mit dessen
hilfe ein 4 1
die vielfachen erkenntnisse systematisch
geordnet werden können
im handschriftlichen nachlass heißt es
dazu
alle erkenntnisse und ein ganzes
derselben muss einer regel gemäss sein
regellosigkeit ist zugleich unvernunft
vernunft ist demnach weiterhin für kant
auch ein vermögen der regelhaftigkeit
der ordnung und system aktivität für
erkenntnis überhaupt sie ist ein
allgemeiner orientierungspunkt des
denkens und ist somit in größte
allgemeinheit zitat die beharrliche
bedingung einer willkürlichen handlungen
unter denen der mensch erscheint die
vernunft ist grundlage und prinzip aller
denkt handlungen des menschen in dem die
vernunft als fontane vermögen der
selbstbestimmung von denken und handeln
angenommen wird ab stellt die das moment
der unabhängigkeit von der natur da bzw
die fähigkeit sich wenigstens gedanklich
von den natürlichen bedingungen zu
distanzieren
so sagt kann hat die vernunft in einem
geschöpfe ist ein vermögen die regeln
und absichten des gebrauchs aller seiner
kräfte weit über den natur- und stinkt
zu erweitern und kennt keine grenze
ihrer entwürfe
komischen kurzatmigkeit gefallen hitze
also und dazu auch aus der grundlegung
zur metaphysik besuchen das bekannte
zitat nun findet der mensch in sich
wirklich ein vermögen dadurch er sich
von allen anderen singen ja von sich
selbst sofern er durch gegenstände
appliziert wird unterscheidet und das
ist die vernunft dieses sogar von sich
selbst es von besonderer bedeutung denn
das deutet darauf hin dass die vernunft
eben zugleich dieses rätsels liebe
vermögen ist sich über ihre eigenen
voraussetzungen klar zu werden
inbegriff der vernunft formuliert also
kommt das unerlässliche prinzip der
selbsttätigkeit des denkens wodurch
sichergestellt wird dass das menschliche
denken nicht bloßes computing oder
rechnen ist sondern sich jederzeit
selbst bestimmt das heißt dass die regel
regeln nach welchen die vernunft in
ihrem fluss weisen verfährt nicht von
irgendeiner äußeren substanz oder von
der natur vergleich vorgegeben sein
könnte sondern dass sie sich diese
regeln selbst gegeben haben muss kommt
sagt dennoch bedeutet freiheit im denken
die unterwerfung der vernunft und keine
anderen gesetze als die sie sich selbst
gibt die vernunft muss also so gedacht
werden dass sie keine anderen instanz
verpflichtet wäre nach der sich ihre
entwürfe einrichten einzurichten hätte
das impliziert als logische folge dass
die völlige und unbedingte autonomie das
ursprüngliche rechte
oder als das ursprüngliche recht der
menschlichen vernunft welches keinem
anderen keinen anderen richter erkennt
als selbst wiederum die allgemeinen
menschen vernunft komisch
dieses verständnis der vernunft als
erstes als ursprung prinzip und zugleich
als letztes als letzter grund nämlich
gibt kann die möglichkeit die natur
unserer vernunft als obersten
gerichtshof aller rechte und ansprüche
unserer spekulation zu umschreiben
mit dieser gericht metapher gelingt es
kant klar zu machen dass jeder versuch
die vernunft welt noch einmal aus einem
höheren prinzip oder einer stärkeren ins
land abzuleiten scheitern muss so wie
jede anstrengung natürlich lässt halten
zu überbieten scheitern müssen aus
logischen gründen und in deren
aufschluss über die orientierung im
denken sagt kant und so zerstört
freiheit im denken wenn sie sogar
unabhängig von gesetzen der vernunft
verfahren will
letztendlich sich selbst diese metapher
von der vernunft als im obersten
gerichtshof aller streitigkeiten oder
auch des gestalten richters der die
zeugen nötigt auf die fragen zu
antworten die er ihnen auf vorliegt
versinnbildlichen die so metaphern für
win bildlichen nichts anderes als den
status der vernunft als conditio sine
qua non von contis kessel denken
überhaupt wenn alle begriffe alle fragen
welche uns die reine vernunft vorliegt
nicht etwa in der erfahrung sondern
selbst wieder in der vernunft liegen
dann heißt das dass es für geltung und
beurteilung des der geld von geltung
sozusagen ein außerhalb der vernunft
geben kann mit klaus konrad möchte ich
sagen es damit die vorstellung zitat der
vernunft als obersten gerichtshof in dem
maße notwendig wie erkennen und wollen
überhaupt als sinnvolle begriffe
erachtet werden
das heißt wie das endliche vernunft
wesen sich nicht als bloßes naturwesen
zu betrachten bereit ist gibt dafür den
lokus clasicos an auf kritik da rein von
und bekanntheit
man kann die kritik der reinen vernunft
als den wahren gerichtshof für alle
streitigkeiten derselben ansehen denn
sie ist in die letzteren als welche auf
objektive unmittelbar gr
als welcher auf objekte unmittelbar
gehen nicht mit verwickelt sondern ist
dazu gesetzt die rechts same der
vernunft überhaupt nach den grundsätzen
ihrer ersten institution zu bestimmen
und zu beurteilen
man beachte das kann hier die
gerichtshof metapher einmal auf die
vernunft selbst und dann aber auch auf
die kritik der reinen vernunft bezieht
damit wird besonders deutlich wie kann
die völlige autonomie des vernunft
vermögens als den anspruch der vernunft
ihre eigenen entwürfe gleich beim in
letzter instanz selbst zu beurteilen als
eigentlichen grund für die notwendige
und apodiktische gewissheit von
vorteilen aus reiner vernunft entwirft
dagegen würde der versuch menschliche
vernunft auf psychologisch umwege zu
erklären
über die bloße dink diskretion
bestimmter für die spezies mensch
typische äußerungen möglichkeiten von
deren konstatiert barkeit auf die im
übrigen ungeklärt bleiben die quelle
zurück geschlossen werden müsste nicht
hinauskommen
das ist jetzt etwas was mir sonst
wirklich nicht passiert nämlich einfach
bewerb zu machen
die man am ende nicht mehr weiß für
angefangen hat also es geht darum zu
sagen dass eine psychologische
beschreibung der menschlichen vernunft
lediglich äußerung möglichkeiten die der
menschlichen spezies eigenen wind
beschrieben werden können und das aber
darüber hin nicht hinausgekommen werden
kann
in dem sinne dass nicht gesagt werden
kann welche logische oder welche
prinzipielle quelle
sie haben diese in richtung auf die
begründung fragen oft fruchtlose
erscheinenden bemühungen der an
philosophie auf meint angemerkt nur in
einer kritische idealistischen
philosophie nachdem welt begriff kann
überhaupt erkenntnis auf begriffe aus
begriffen also kognition ex principi ist
die kant rational nennt begründet werden
erkenntnis aus prinzipien heißt aber
weder bloße meinung von der kanzlei
subjektiv und objektiv unzureichendes
für wahr halten noch glaube das ist nach
kant subjektiv zureichend objektiv
unzureichendes für wahr halten sondern
wissen um strengen sinne
das heißt subjektiv und objektiv zu
reichendes für wahr halten
aus dem methodenlehre des kipper kapitel
meinem wissen und glauben ganz nah an
dieser stelle auch der probier schneien
das für wahr halten ob es überzeugung
oder bloße überredung sei ist also
äußerlich die möglichkeit das selbe
mitzuteilen und dem das für wahr halten
für jedes menschen und dafür warten für
jedes menschen von uns gültig zu
befinden
ja vielleicht haben wir das können wir
noch nur ein bisschen rum fahren
ich komme so zu sagen jetzt zum schluss
vor allem aus bin erst der gerichtshof
metapher folgen einige wichtige dinge
zum ersten ist deutlich dass sich aus
der idee der kritischen prüfung ergibt
dass vernunft bei kant niemals als welt
prinzip oder weltseele oder weltweit
verstanden werden kann sondern immer nur
als ein spezifisch menschliche vermögen
zweitens des weiteren zeigt sich
deutlich dass die kritische vernunft
bekannt als das eigentliche
strukturprinzip des denkens angesehen
wird und somit den vorher postulierten
vorschlag den vorher postulierte
vorschlag bestätigt den kantischen
vernunft begriff als seine implizite
variante des geistes anzunehmen
drittens aber wird in der autonomie und
selbständigkeit forderung der subjekt
charakter beziehungsweise das
reflexionsvermögen ich mit meiner
einschätzung nach in allen jedenfalls
idealistischen gleich konzeptionen der
philosophie erscheint besonders
eindringlichkeit mehr
dieses paradigma indes vernünftigen
durch hunt wagner in seinen arbeiten zum
reflexion begriff aufzuscheinen als auch
durch friedrich kaulbach in seiner
philosophie oder sein versuch die
struktur der subjektivität in der
konstruktion der perspektive tät zu
fassen will man nun nach alledem so etwa
wie eine kurze antwort kann
auf die frage was es mit dem geist auf
sich hat haben formulieren so würde ich
gerne auf kampf
auf kampf aufklärung impetus verweisen
sapere aude der geist besteht der den
menschen eigenen fähigkeit und freiheit
seinen verstand ohne fremde hilfe zu
gebrauchen
der geist ist das was wir als bedingung
dafür annehmen würden jemanden als einen
vernünftigen menschen angesehen
das ist also keineswegs etwa die
zuschreibung eines besonderen
außergewöhnlichen vermögens wie man es
bei lebensphilosophie sowie vielleicht
finden könnte also eine besondere
künstlerische begabung oder so etwas
oder ein hoher iq sondern ist schlicht
die realisierung unseres menschseins